maybe like lizzie why don't you clap
back why don't you clap back cause [ __ ]
i'm winning hoe lizzo was clapping back
in the best way possible
by not clapping back
big fish
[Applause]
yep the truth hurts singer's name
trended all weekend long after comedian
arie spears made comments about her body
to the art of dialogue
i can't get past the fact that she looks
like emoji
yo
very beautiful girl she's got a very
pretty face
but she keeps showing her body off
like come on man
come on yo
aries went on to make comments about his
own body too but insisted his quote
swagger and confidence made up for what
he lacked i'm sorry listen i ain't the
most in shape
in the world but i still you know when
you funny and you got swagger and
confidence
and and you decent looking i think i'm
at least handsome
you get
as for what he thinks about lizzo the
comic doubled down taking this shot at
the singer
but a woman that's built like a plate of
mashed potatoes is in trouble
but liza proved being blessed and
unbothered is the best revenge
slightly addressing the controversy on
stage at the vmas as she accepted the
trophy for video for good and now
to the [ __ ] that got something to say
about me and the press
you know what i'm not gonna say nothing
well she definitely said something
maybe like lizzie why don't you clap
back why don't you clap back cause [ __ ]
i'm winning ho
[Applause]
safe to say there is no slowing down for
lizzo before the show she walked the red
carpet in this over the top dark blue
gown rocking a dramatic dark lip color
and a retro classic hairdo i'm feeling
good as hell and she brought the good
vibes to the stage shutting up anyone
who has something bad to say with this
show-stopping performance
[Music]
he call me
[Music]